c'est la question que je pose vous
pouvez y répondre en même temps
également voilà c'est après sa
prestation leur vision est ce la fin
pour madonna oui non il ya des petits as
we noms qui vont s'afficher
ici c'est la question qu'on s'est posée
magali parce que madonna c'est une icône
pour ce qu'elle représente il y en a
plein des trojans comme maman c'est une
icône pour ce qu'elle est et ce qu'elle
représente
il ya plein de chanteurs on découvre ces
genres on le découvre maintenant en le
savent pas chanter mais par contre est
une star parce qu'ils britney spears qui
chantent en play-back qui tu penses à
britney spears qui chantent en play-back
tout le long aussi de ses moyens et sa
demi fond du show c'est une fille qui
sait faire du show et elle me la fait
pas une chanteuse c'est une showgirl
fabio ce qu'on dit c'est pas idiot
damman que c'est une chanteuse sur la
chambre m tu peux réussir la trace
non je ne suis pas idiot ce qu elle a
dit j'ai pas dis tu étais pas idiote et
un petit on est sur une phrase mais
regardez est ce que ceux qui ont vu
johnny sur scène
ouais il ya des concerts de johnny qui
chantait faux il est ivre on a parlé du
concert à las vegas c'est pas tout ça
mais le temps non mais ce que veut dire
c'est que j'adore johnny et puis ça
arrive ça arrive
ce sont des gens singulier moi j'ai un
mois j'ai de l'affection pour madonna ok
elle une carrière incroyable on peut pas
reprocher à madonna la fc foix remo
qu'elle s'était elle s'est foiré
bon bah voilà minutes après le début des
foyers un peu indulgents avec ces gens
c'est gentil nartoof qui tu es payé un
million et demi d'euros pour être
indulgent j'y vois là un peu foiré mais
c'est quand même madonna qui servait
madonna bon j'ai voulu par une catéchèse
de tourner la tap autorise tout d'accord
avec paiement m alors oui c'est plus le
fait que chantal moi je les jeux les
aussi vu quand elles étaient venus en
petit comité faire son concert à
l'olympia où ça a été une catastrophe et
s'était barré très rapidement alors que
les places étaient hors de prix etc
mais en plus du fait qu'elle chante mal
physiquement je sais pas ça choque
personne qui ressemble plus à la poupée
du musée grévin que l'appel à questions
que c'est beau ça devient ridicule à un
nouveau attendu mais il faut juste
savoir que prochains concerts les placer
entre 250 et 800 euros
si pour 800 euros vous avez quelqu'un
qui chante faux qui est totalement
botoxée qui bouge plus locale est plus
chaud et plus de chansons qu'est ce
qu'on va voir ce qu'elle bougeait plus
qu'est ce qu'on va voir mathieu valbuena
je pose la question à lui parce que je
suis on a une réponse comme jamais non
mais moi j'ai trouvé ça catastrophique
j'en ferais presque pleurer devant ma
télé quand j'ai du spo elle descendait
ses marchés c'est d'un ridicule elle
faisait une marche après l'autre comme
si elle avait une hanche pt
[Rires]
avec son chat et où ils avaient vraiment
c'était complètement foiré georges
cottier la tenue sachant qu'on attendait
quand même ce retour que c'était détruit
une promo énorme quelques lesquels
laquelle s'est arrêté pendant des années
pour s'occuper de ces gosses et que je
deviens le reprenez le travail et les
gens réalisent en cette fin prête et là
on se rend compte que c'est on va
présenter voilà on doit pas encore cinq
secondes
est-ce qu'elle doit s'arrêter ou plus
largement est ce que les stars quand on
accouche donc plus la voix d'appareils
michel sardou pendant soixante dix ans a
dit j'ai pu avoir que j'avais avant
j'arrête
alors on en soit c'est la première fois
qu'elle est ce qu'il faut s'arrêter au
top ou être que là il ya un concert qui
arrivent avec des plaies jusqu'à 800
euros
elle peut plus tellement bougé pour
faire le show elle peut plus tellement
chanté on va tous vieillir un jour c'est
pas de la vieille au phoque be c'est
juste est-ce qu'il faut pas s'arrêter au
top c'est la question que je vous pose
il restait pour en parler daniel et puis
mes regards des pigeonneaux qu'on avance
là mais regardez les fiches de normes
guyomard et on parle trop de sel dans
cette émission je connaissais pas non
oui parce qu'elle à côté de toi je veux
la vie de daniel dejean conserver trois
secondes et après le tient parce qu'elle
a donné une interview d'ailleurs ces
flux madonna juste pour nous bazil dany
pour moi je veux juste défendre dans la
prestation madonna parce que quand vous
avez un corps séparé y ait le bras qui
avait je comprends qu'on chante faux et
qu'on puisse pas beaucoup bougé parce
que c'est quand même c'est du sport et
le les spectacles les concerts qui sont
prévues en france au grand rex en
février 2020 j'ai vérifié ce matin c'est
quasiment complet et je pense que même
quand un artiste est un petit peu au
bout je les ai vécus avec barbara
j'étais fan elle était elle était
fatiguée savoie évidemment n'était plus
comme avant et j'étais tellement
heureuse de la voir sur scène j'aurais
aimé qu'elle chante jusqu'à 60 ans donc
voilà je pense qu'ils les fans ont
besoin quand même
et quand on aime quelqu'un on lève avec
ses défauts donc j attendais ce qui est
un petit peu dur et j'avoue c'est dur ça
l'est pour tout le monde mais c'est vrai
que forcément comme cd des femmes qu'on
a connus jeunes qu'on a connus jeunes
bas quand on les voit arriver avec
beaucoup de maquillage et beaucoup
d'artifices pour cacher un peu le visage
et puis forcément le coup les mains
trahissent un petit peu là vibrant la
vie est ainsi faite mais est ce que dans
ces cas là il faut continuer à assumer
sur la sq devraient pas assumé son
ajustement c'est pas comme ça que ces
révisions céline dion aval à célyne
durand mais elle a des grandes robes on
dirait une héroïne de dynastie elle sera
jamais vraiment démodé céline dion va
montrer sa culotte tout le temps comme
si elle avait 30 ans ou 20 ans on dirait
vous à la plage en fait le jeune mec
vous êtes vous êtes en bungee à 45 ans
vous ya des moments où vous êtes gros
test vous voyez oui mais c'est vrai mais
à 45 ans j'ai le corps que tu ne m'aimes
pas eu à 18 samedi que la chance que
j'ai voilà voilà
en attendant elle a donné une interview
cette nuit oui elle a donné unitaire de
cette nuée elle dit je suis qui je suis
personne ne fais ce que je fais il ya
personne dans ma position je suis foutu
ni pour avoir 60 ans et on reproche de
ne pas être assez jolie et de mal
chanter quoi que je fasse je ferais mal
pour ceux qui ne m'aiment pas les mots
puisqu'il doit pas savoir si on va faire
de madonna tout leur le problème frêche
chanter man au delà qu'elles
vieillissent et après ça il ya trois ans
je vis à vis que demers ça veut rien
dire guillaume gille le disent les amis
comme vous m'énervez en passer un autre
sujet est certes un sondage là dessus en
régie non ah oui on en a justement
regardez bien avec la question après sa
prestation l'eurovision est afin pour
madonna achèterait c'est très mitigé
mais quand même voilà il y en a sur deux
qui pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut savoir
partir peut-être sur un succès et pas
arrêter le déclin c'est difficile de
partir mais faut partir avant le déclin
si magali tu peux en prendre bonne note
ce serait pas mal